this program welcome to this afternoon's
a sunset Safari where we have just just
caught up but with their little chief
himself who seems to be after something
that he's no it's just after a different
shady spot a very good afternoon to you
my name is Jamie and this afternoon
Craig is on camera with me and we're
live from Juma private game reserve
which is in the greater Kruger National
Park area of South Africa now because
this is a live Safari first of all when
we start our safaris the animals do this
to us as a part of Coles law but also at
the same time you can send through your
questions and you can do that on hashtag
Safari live on Twitter alternatively you
can send them through in the comments
section of YouTube right great well
we're going to have to move are we not a
little boy what is it doing what are you
doing
bit of an odd mood this afternoon now it
is quite warm as I'm sure you're going
to be told repeatedly by all three of us
who are out this afternoon it is a
Karstens told me three times what it is
it's 37 and
that she's seven and ninety something
something like that it's hot it's hot
and it's sweaty
98 I'm sorry Kirsten oh you did tell me
three times but I forgot it
I don't know why he's chosen to lie
there but I think it's because the
ground is nice and wet so I said that
it's hot husana this morning for those
of you who missed it had a some water
I suppose rotten in Pilot caucus that he
was nibbling on and he took a little bit
of it down here into the drainage line
behind the down wall it's the perfect
spot to come on a hot afternoon but it
does mean that there's no breeze so it's
all fine and well being down here in the
shade but there's actually nothing to
keep you cool or to keep the flies away
and I think that's why Hasan has gone to
lie where he has I think his patch where
he was initially has got quite warm and
he's decided upon our arrival I think we
just provided the final layer of
motivation necessary to get up move and
then to curl up down there underneath
that pile of logs and make our lives
very difficult it is hotter down here
Hassan I don't know whether you realize
this but it's definitely hotter down
here than it is up there there's no
breeze at all but because this is an
overflow or a drainage line we're
actually in a riverbed yeah there's
still quite a lot of dampness to the
soil
that's probably why he is where he is
I'm almost tempted to go join him
obviously not right there now this
morning we found him on foot
unfortunately due to an attack of the
gremlins we didn't manage to get him
live on foot but we went down hope he
was busy looking at the monkeys and I
was trying to tell him that husana was
was right at his feet basically looking
at us so he we did find him on foot this
morning it's very nice I always enjoy
spending time with a special leopard on
foot because he is so relaxed with us
hey my boy
you beautifully framed
child of the universe wants to know that
why husana doesn't go take a dip in the
water it's a it's an interesting one I
could tell you straight up that lions
and leopards don't particularly like to
wallow in water they don't like having
wet fur they've got quite thick fur
what's up boy something odd about him
today normally he'd have passed out
already maybe he is just so died so hot
he can't so I could tell you that lions
and leopards don't like it he could find
himself a puddle to wallow in but you
never see leopards doing that how would
having said you never see leopards doing
that all lions I know that Scotty in the
Masai Mara a few months ago had this
amazing sighting of lions wallowing
which you never get to hear about or
read about or even really see pictures
of and there's no reason why they
shouldn't in at some point be a lift
order that doesn't read the books that
decides it actually likes water
but generally speaking even on the
hottest of the hot days
leopards will not go and lie in water Oh
obviously we right next to the dam there
is no way that husana would go in line
there and there's a very good reason for
that it is because there's crocodiles
quite frankly and quite simply it's too
big of a risk I'm not the only person
out on this glorious Lee hot afternoon
sweating our way through it and Sydney
is Artemis go and see how he feels about
the seat a very very good afternoon and
most of all welcome to the beginning of
the afternoon game drive this is Sydney
a former enemy cozy and I'm travelling
with Sansa who is my camera operator
this afternoon hopefully we are going to
get you see quite a lot of interesting
animals I don't have a specific target
this afternoon I will be looking for a
general game hopefully we are going to
see a lot
so the weather is so hot at the moment
I'm sure this kind of weather will be
restricting quite a lot of movement on
this animus this afternoon hello hello
and for incase if you would like to talk
to us you can follow us on Twitter
hashtag suffer live you can also follow
us on YouTube chat stream how the grass
is growing very quickly here after the
heavy rains I can see that the Predators
can easily get camouflage it's green
everywhere this bush looks very
impressive it's beautiful here
I have been away just for about a couple
of days but now I am seeing quite a lot
of changes at the moment
so now let's cross over to Tristan who's
got the beautiful hippopotamus indeed we
are out and about as well and you can
see that we are sitting with the animals
that have the exact right idea
in afternoon heat as we put this off
it's not as bad as yesterday but it's
still quite warm and so you'll find
these guys are going to position
themselves just inside before suck dam
and enjoy a spot of bathing
of course it's scuba Steve and snorkel
Sarah and that's we are talking about
Prince gets very angry because we call
them Scuba Steve and snorkel Sarah and
me don't actually check if it's the same
hippos but anyway he's not here anymore
so he can't shout at us my name is
Kristen on camera but Sebastian this
afternoon and it is a very warm welcome
to all of you
hopefully we'll enjoy having us out and
about with you during the course of
today and the kind of plan for this
afternoon for us is to head towards
tortured we had 10 Ghana and Colombo
there this morning and so we're gonna
try and see if we couldn't find them
again unfortunately both of them were
quite mobile and Colombo got a fright
when she saw it in Ghana from afar and
ran and so it's gonna be a bit tricky to
find them but hopefully they'll be on
one of them will be on a man somewhere
with a bit of shade and we'll get lucky
so that's the kind of plan for the
afternoon and we also didn't have wild
dogs this morning for those either think
well well wondering why they weren't on
the show well through arts on tracking
team and so we were just trying to find
some stuff and we found obviously the
dogs and they'd ran into chitwa before
the show we could get Juma back on line
and then I was sitting on in Colombo we
found him I think was about two minutes
to go in the show and they were quite
far to the eastern is gonna be a bit
tricky with signal and the likes but we
try our best to see if we can find him
on that side of the world but you can
see these hippos are very very sleepy
Scuba Steve you tired boy must be a
happy hippo though now that his damage
got water once again and that he is able
to kind of sit and take it very very
easy and enjoy a bit of water and you'll
see there's a little box picker that's
on the back that's quite hot you can see
how it's got its mouth open and he's
basically practicing law flutter which
is equivalent of a cat or a dog panting
Marcelle how long do hippos live for
well generally in the wild you'll find
that hippos will live to about 30 years
they can't go a little bit older than
that but it's you know in wild given
that they fight with one another these
predators those kind of things generally
the lifespan is a little bit shorter but
look at that I expect you see arts
opening one of the wounds on the hippos
back because that's why it's trying to
cause a bit of bleeding to start so that
it actually drink the blood and get that
so it's not actually looking for any
parasite it's trying to actually get
some blood flow going in that little
wound that is on the back but doesn't
seem like any blood is actually coming
out at this stage so if back to the kind
of age thing is that these guys
obviously in the wild there's a lot of
different factors whereas in captivity
they would be able to be fed they'd have
its care they would you know have no
worries about predation and so they can
go to about thirty five in captivity but
thirty generally in the wild would be
quite an old hippos I mean they are one
or two you probably get to 35 but not
that often I'm sure this hippo wants to
go in the water completely to stop the
oxpecker picking at any wounds but
hasn't quite rolled over just yet you
can see the one next to it is kind of
cantered to the side so sometimes when
they get a little bit kind of dry on one
spot
they'll just canter left or right and
that will allow them to keep their body
nice and covered and really kind of cool
down and then to stop too much
dehydration but quite cool little ox
picker right between his head best of
friends really at this stage oh he's
just too lazy to care about the oxpecker
you can see a little flick of the ears
so that'll be just to get water out of
the ears itself often when they go
underwater there's a little bit of extra
moisture that collects once that is
turned and sealed and then they just
flick that out to make sure that the
water doesn't go in and cause any issues
inside there so quite a little care
system when you find oxpecker sometimes
we'll try and kind of go towards the
ears to try to look for parasites and
then they flick them to just to try and
stop it
it's this speaker it's really going to
tell nothing these hippos hides
unfortunately they're getting rather
hammered you see that pork speaker must
be so hot the fact that it's got its
mouth open like that after every kind of
pick you
an idea of how warm it is I mean we're
close to a hundred degrees Fahrenheit
again today and so in that in the Sun
like that it's going to be very very hot
this time you say that Alex Baker looks
like it's actually laughing about it
well I suppose say yes you'd imagine it
having that sinister evil laugh as it
picks and breaks open the skin maybe
that's how it's laughing I don't know
it'd have to kind of think of a ox
pickle off would it be deep and sinister
would it be high-pitched and squeaky
that would make it quite funny I'm not
quite sure as to which kind of laugh a
oxpecker would have I reckon if they're
picking her away it's cause and so Casey
reckons it should be ha ha ha so that's
little kind of laugh I reckon you've
probably quite spot on because they I
mean they don't have exactly have a
high-pitched call at the best of times
but it's falling asleep underwater but
they don't have a high-pitched call at
the best of times and so you know I
reckon that's probably about right good
we getting absolutely baked in the Sun
yeah so you're gonna try to carry on and
get a bit of airflow before we catch a
heat stroke it's very very hot and
unlike the hippos we are not wallowing
in water and so we're going to just try
and kind of move and see if we can find
some semblance of shade Scuba Steve you
have a good day there buddy enjoy your
nap hopefully we'll see you out and
about a little bit later good we're
gonna keep heading off towards Torchwood
in the meantime though that sends you up
to the Masai Mara so that's from India
mr. injury can say good afternoon now
this is very interesting everybody good
afternoon before I give you all the
greeting in the housekeeping look at
that there is an elephant and there's an
Egret standing on its back I've never
seen that before
now often we're asked why it is that
oxpeckers don't sit on elephants and
well sometimes we say they just don't
tolerate them we know that elephants of
course have very thick skin and so they
probably don't have anything like that a
number of external parasites it's
something like an Impala or Buffalo
Rhino might have but the answer that
elephants just don't tolerate Birds is
very clearly shown to be fault
yeah isn't that interesting good
afternoon and welcome to the Masai Mara
my name is James Henry it's marvelous to
have you with us here for the next two
hours on our Sunday afternoon Drive I
don't know what I like to say soon the
afternoon like that but I do and say our
child pleasing the hashtags of fire live
on Twitter and the YouTube chat stream
we are in the territory of the sauce
ours tree pride we did see them lying
under a tree about hmm 20 minutes ago
now we came to look and see if we could
find the mails and whatever else was
going on around here and if we get very
lucky we might find the mails but we'll
probably go back to the sausages and
very shortly so that is the state of
play down south here with the sausage
tree pride and the elephants of course
we have our TV show a little bit later
if you'd like to watch us you can join
us on s ABC 3 if you're in South Africa
otherwise you might be able to catch it
on YouTube lots of beautiful egrets
alright should we drive along I must of
course tell you that the inimitable
Peter Bungay is on camera he has got all
5 fingers
attached to his left hand it has
continued
oops Quran and have another look at
these elephants because the Lions
weren't far from here earlier Anna there
is a fire to the left we were told
yesterday that perhaps people were
harvesting bees
well not harvesting bees harvesting
honey I'm not sure that that's what's
going on there though
maybe there might be I'll have another
look we'll get a little bit closer I
just want to go and check at the buffalo
carcass from yesterday as well before we
go back to the pride the males might
just be lounging there it's not far from
where we are now
lovely picture those elephants in those
egrets so we'll just try and get a
little bit closer to them I think ah I
see now where that other vehicle
disappeared two chaps it went around to
where we had the Buffalo and the sausage
tree prod yesterday
driving on through here it is a
beautiful beautiful afternoon out
we've got about I'm gonna say an hour
and a half left of light which is just
delightful soft Maura light and Maura
colours
and it's been quite a nice hot day which
means that if there are lines about you
can almost be guarantee that they'll be
lying under one of the yeah shall we say
thinly dispersed trees
let's have a look there the elephants
and the mountain and the harvesters
honey harvesters I can imagine by my
saying that there are honey harvesters
there are probably people at home
thinking to themselves how could they
don't they know that bees are endangered
how could they treat them like that I
think you'll probably find the bezel go
back to their original spot there I also
think you'll find the amount of be
harvesting that goes on here or honey
harvesting that goes on probably effects
the bee population from very little
indeed much less for example than the
perhaps even the farming of avocadoes
Devi we dealed with wildfires in Africa
in the following manner and we have a
traditional fire dance and once we've
completed the dance we run away
screaming like this deaf you should put
the camera on me I'll show you okay like
this run really fast in that Tim's to
help us to get away from the wildfires
here in Africa obviously that's not
really true we deal with them in much
the same way as you do anywhere else in
the world with helicopters dropping
water on them with back burns so at a
place like Juma or in an area like this
what you'll do is set a back burn in
other words you'll start to burn a piece
of ground towards the fire against the
wind because obviously fire moves with
the wind and you have to do that very
carefully with a big team of people it's
quite a skilled job and it's quite a
scary job because the fire can jump
behind you and then you can get yourself
into real trouble that's generally how
we do it often you can just let them
burn out their oats
you know because they need three things
they need fuel they need
try atmosphere and they need heat so
they've they've gotta have those three
things in order to in order to burn
effectively you'll find that as night
falls in a lot of these grassland areas
the fires will die down and actually
quite easy to put out once the
temperature drops and if there isn't too
much wind it is very different however
in areas where you have aromatic or oily
trees if you know what I mean and so
it's a wild fire rushing through the
mara is nothing like a wild fire rushing
through California through the trees
they're all through some of those
Australian gum trees those are far more
dangerous than any fires that we have
here because the trees you know
obviously explode into into fire I'm
gonna continue with my fire discussion
once we've looked at these elephants the
one behind does not look particularly
happy I don't know why that should be
the case I mean we're a long way from
beautiful with all the egrets isn't it
lovely so we're not gonna get any closer
we're just gonna let her be not sure
while she's marching her crew closer to
us that seems a bit odd
while you're getting comms there boom
game what is she saying I'm getting
nothing you just get bit anyway while
the elephants have calmed down there are
some parts of South Africa where
obviously we do have much more dangerous
wildfires and in fact down in the
Eastern Cape and Western Cape of South
Africa there are currently tremendously
dangerous wildfires my uncle nearly lost
his home yesterday to wildfires in the
hermanus region and that burns in the
fan boss area so those are very oily
plants that sort of exploded to fire and
carry fire much like the trees in a
place like California or in Australia
would so in an area like this yes we do
get wildfires deal with them either by
letting them burn out or putting in back
burns all right so that's my fire
discussion let's go back across to South
Africa where Jamie Patterson is with the
star it sounds like a stunning sighting
with James in the Mara nothing like
spending time with elephants across that
side as for this crazy cat I don't know
what his deal is
he was sitting curled up quite
comfortably behind the logs then he
decided to come and lie down right in
front of our vehicle we're not even the
camera could actually see him so then I
moved back a little bit just to put some
space between myself and him because I
can't see what he's doing down there and
obviously we can't spend our afternoon
talking about the front part of my
vehicle so I moved back and I stopped
and I switched off and then you know
what the silly silly creature did it is
again he got up and he walked to us and
he laid down in front of right in front
of the vehicle
I mean basically lying up against it and
I don't know why because surely it's hot
I mean the vehicles been running for not
very long but still enough to produce
heat I can feel the heat coming up
through the bottom of the car the base
of the car so why on earth did he decide
that that was where he wanted to be
silly cat I thought maybe it was because
I'd accidentally missed his he maybe
moved his meat here and I'd missed it
and I'd driven over it oh maybe I did no
he's no he's not he just wants to be
where I was parked I think maybe our
vehicle tires flattened the grass there
or something I don't know you weirdo boy
you absolute weirdo maybe it's just the
best spot so reads a lot a very warm
welcome sir reads a lot as a name I have
not heard before which means that we are
greeting as far as we know a new viewer
and also reads a lot wants to know am I
not scared of being this close to a big
cat every single animal that we see out
here is wild and should be treated as
such that means a degree of respect
constantly reading their behavior that's
why we do what we do is because we've
spent many years doing so having said
that these cats are perfectly relaxed
with the presence of Safari vehicles
they've grown up with Safari vehicles
this particular young leopard who if you
continue to watch which you will because
you going to become addicted this
particular cat we've watched grow up
since he was a few hours old which is
really very special so he's had Safari
vehicles as part of his environment
since he was little and it has allowed
us a totally unparalleled insight into
his life so he does not see us as food
we don't look like food there are a lot
of people who will tell you that animals
cannot identify individual people we're
now in a vehicle I'm not convinced by
that I think that they know that we're
here obviously we're talking they can
see us I mean if they can pick out an
individual Impala they can pick out a
person sitting on a car but they don't
associate us as a threat and they do not
associate us with food so that
combination means that as long as they
are not afraid of us we are perfectly
safe where we are but we always treat
the animals carefully and we make sure
that we're constantly watching their
behavior this is exciting news something
that wants to stay well away from husana
but that I've been looking forward to
seeing
this time of year Tristan's found one go
have a look indeed a likely show should
stay well away from husana because we
know husana grabbed one of these last
week but it's not that's that we are
worried about you can see that's a big
adult kudu female that is not pregnant
in any way and so husana wouldn't target
that in particular but it's a tiny
little baby moving around in amongst
those two adults tricky to see but it's
behind that one I think let's see if
it'll move I can see a bit of movement
behind that one it's so small that it's
completely hidden by these adults and
seems to be a little bit shy of us at
this stage I don't know why obviously
well I actually do know why I mean
supposed to be a big object it's a bit
kind of nervous as to what we are and
what we do and so it will be trying to
stay close to mommy I see the little
head a little one look if it's ears it's
so much bigger than the rest of its head
and that is a very new baby probably
within I would say the last few days you
can see look hearts smelling us and
trying to listen to us it's probably
thinking itself mom what is this it's so
big I don't know is it something that I
must run away from must I stay still but
of course if mom is staying still and
then kind of just watching us then it
will be okay but it is absolutely tiny
you can see it doesn't even go past
mom's tale yet so I believe a lot of you
are moving and eyeing it's the cuteness
of this little baby could do they are
really cute I like baby could be because
they everything just looks too big for
their head you know there's ears or
ridiculous in comparison to the size of
their head and then on top of that they
have long legs that they kind of bound
around with Gina you say it's little
lips are so cute is could you have that
little white marking on their lips and
say it can be quite cute particularly in
the little babies you'll often kind of
see this little cute kind of face
looking at you and I'll just love how
the little nostril is flaring as well
trying to just work out what exactly we
are on whether or not she needs to be
worried I don't know if it's a boy or a
girl yet actually to be honest we just
kind of have seen this little tiny head
popping up in your mom but so cool to
see the baby animals are very cute
things there's no doubt about it is most
animals that
see when they're young are very very
cute of course it does need to be
careful that took one because we see our
chairs and lots of predators that will
be around and like Jamie rightly said
husana would be very eager to grab that
little one so would wild dog so it can
eat in Ghana pretty much anything really
that's a predator even hyenas would like
to go after a small could you like that
and they do target them quite often and
we find a lot of young kudu of that size
being eaten particularly by wild dogs
they they tend to grab him quite
regularly they can kind of quiz panic
and get hold of these little ones but
you can see out staying close to mom
while we here just to make sure
everything's okay
you might go for a little drink of milk
there we go are you wanting to suckle
that one no we're too interesting we
need to see investigate us a little bit
more isn't that cute shame you can see
mom in the background how much she's
behaving because she must be incredibly
warm at the moment you can see it a
Collette rocking back and forth motion
that's all just much like any of the
other animals trying to cool down her
rate of breathing is much faster now
giraffe cool how long will a little kudu
like this nurse for well you normally
see them kind of nursing like this for
about the first three months and then
they start to really kind of concentrate
more on vegetation some of them will be
quite cheeky and I'll try a little bit
longer look at sniffing little tail
hello mom no I don't just follow along
right next to it and you can see the
size difference there it can even fit
underneath its mother completely so you
can see it's standing between mom's legs
at the moment which is very very cute
and so know me about three months and
then they start to kind of go more on to
cross some of them will be a bit cheeky
and they'll try a little bit longer than
that and try and bully their moms into
suckling more but just theoretically
they should be going onto leaves already
at around sort of even earlier than that
some of them it's sort of a two months
can I really start feeding on a bit of
vegetation but they will try and suckle
and try and get as much milk out of mom
for as long as possible in any baby
animal radius like that now where you
off to
are you gonna go exploring let's be very
careful about doing this so that's one
thing about little baby could if they
separate like that from their mother
this is where a lipid would really want
to be around because it would be able to
get to that kudu before mom could
protect it and that would be dangerous
now it's going to go in almost looks
like it wants to investigate in male
Impala that's across the road so Skyy
who's eight years old is a nice size
comparison between the little baby could
you in the Impala male why do they have
stripes on their body well the simple
reason for that scar is because most of
their time is spent in thick dense areas
now if you look where it's standing
there do you see that there's a bit of
shade and then there's a bit of light on
the leaves and so win and kudu is behind
a few trees that white marking that you
see there helps to break at the outline
of this kudu so what that means is it
basically makes it very difficult to see
the exact shape of the kudu in those
little sort of areas with is light and
dark and it helps the critter to
camouflage more which means it hides
away better from predators and it makes
it easier for these guys to then kind of
be able to fool predators into thinking
that they're not there so that's
basically why they've got it is all just
part of camouflage and to help them stay
as hidden as possible you can see it's
on the edge of the road now quite cool
actually to see I think it's quite
curious about this Impala male is the
umbilical cord still attached kiss
that's quite cool work it's very
difficult on these little monitors to
see much but yes there it is it's drying
up a little bit so like I say only a few
days old I would imagine this little one
and an umbilical cord is starting to dry
and also should be its sniffing around
imagine what it must be like for this
little one everything smells everything
is new it's just all about investigating
and trying to figure out its world now
mom looks very impressed with her she's
kind of quite proud of her little one at
this stage I'm just kind of standing
over it and having a look and there's
the kind of size difference between the
two and you can see how much bigger the
females are and why it was such an
impressive kill that husana made um I
mean that could you there's probably
I would say two to two-and-a-half times
the size of what husana is and so for
him to bring that down plus a fetus that
was inside that female is quite
something but anyway we're going to kind
of carry on and see what else we can
find and something that is also got some
in strength like Hosanna is a little
insect that Sydney has something is
every year the dung beetles are so
fascinating I've been here for the past
few minutes and a lot of things has been
happening I just want to get over here
so that we can have a nice discussion
about these majestic and beautiful
insects look this is a very big fight
taking place here look how many of about
four of them are involved on a fight
look at this year so we have seen quite
a lot of boss already which has been
checking out different ones big ones so
there's quite a lot of competition going
on look another one is now about to
leave they did they damn pile so listen
to that you can hear them when they are
fighting when they are pushing each
other you can hear some rattling sound
this is amazing look at this one two
three four there's quite a lot of big
balls still here so but I want to first
see which droppings are these from so I
can see that here on the ground there's
evidence such as this this is the marula
fruit it's clear that this is the other
end dropping so but this I don't think
is fair enough to call them droppings at
this stage because this insects are
feeding here so now is food this is food
its food for the dung beetles it's no
longer droppings later the column
droppings when they are not ended
now when other animals are feeding this
is food so let me smell this food the
jungle because they don't smell bad so
it's just like the normal elephant
drooping smell so here these dung
beetles are assisting a lot if you can
check there's quite a lot of flies here
you can see look at this there is too
much flies here does this fly is some of
them are laying some X here at the
moment and when the Ling it's done
bitters at the same time they are
rolling the balls and destroying the X
at the same time so they are helping us
in order to control the population of
flies naturally dung beetles are there
in order to control the balance when it
comes to the population of flies so this
is very much interesting after this
there some of them are going deep this
side some are going down on this road so
they are going to find a nice port and
bury these kind of balls
so dung beetles when talking in terms of
the strength the dung beetles they are
very much strong yes the strongest
animal in the whole world is the
elephant but when talking in terms of
the strength to weight ratio dung beetle
is the best so they are all looking very
much dirty and oh this even a kennel
here look at this oh here we might see a
fighter there because I can see it's
tree you see it's going back again look
at that look at that look at that now
now it's a fight look at that this is
amazing when you see that is three you
must know that that what is lost is what
is running away now with with the drug
is right now they are fighting
for nothing look at that so the other
one is trying to escape and they still
they fight this one is still looking for
that one with a ball you can see so
let's see maybe he's gonna manage to
find this one with a ball here then we
might see another look it's coming
towards that direction look at that the
fire disk is going to carry on something
interesting so this one is driving over
his wife now because the one which is
holding so it okay now only wants to get
the ball and the wife away Tim is
rolling drive over the wife this does
will discourage so look at oh now he's
fighting that one
look at that this is amazing now he's
driving the ball much more decide maybe
there was just a little bit of
disagreements between the husband and
wife because the husband is the one
normal who pushes the wife is having a
lift so after this you will see the
little ones inside they're going to be
able to eat because when they are hiding
when the XH is dung beetles they've got
a complete lifecycle so when they hatch
the eggs little ones they have to be
able to lava must be able to eat by the
fresh path of these droppings and this
novice when they are still going through
the lava stage they also experience
problems because some of the animals
such as the honey badgers they like to
dig they they like to dig this dung ball
balls and collect them in order to eat
the larvae so that is something which is
also controls the population of dung
beetles so you can see now this sort of
big balls coming out again look at that
I can see another one is is coming out
now is taken through that side so that
is quite a very big ball
well they can't be able to hate each
other
I have seen some of the dung beetles
they have got short limbs some of them
has got broken legs here because of
involving themselves in this kind of
thighs and apart from this there are
some of also other animals who predate
the dung beetles these bears who eat
them are they've got a very strong
chitinous cover which is very hard some
of them they learned on their back when
they come to these droppings so they
their skin is very much hard so you can
see the elephants the reason why they
look another one is landing oh we just
landed no colonel from what I have seen
here today I have noticed that is a
difference because all these climbing
they are very much clean and the ones
who are pushing are looking very dirty
all the time if you can check here the
females are not doing anything so the
easiest way for me to distinguish
between the male and female is to check
the one who's got dirty wings is the
male I'm seeing here and the females
their bodies are looking very shiny so
the female's body are shining and the
male's bodies they are looking much more
duty and much more Brown
and this is one of the best sightings so
the elephants are the ones who are
giving this dung beetles quite a lot of
nutritious food at the moment so let's
pick clickers over to James and see if
those elephants are not excreting food
for the dung beetles right everybody
we've been spending a very interesting
time here while you've been having a
very interesting time with the boring
beauties of dung and what's interesting
here is that an elephant died yesterday
around here we met some Rangers who told
us that we came back into this area to
see what was going to happen if perhaps
it would be surrounded by a fight
between the border pride and the sausage
tree pride as they decided who was going
to have the spoils instead what we came
across was a big pile of soil so the
Rangers buried the elephant that died
here yesterday we don't know why yet
I'll phone David and try and find out I
suspect that probably were worried that
it may have died of some disease and
instead of risking you know the prey art
here they just the world let's put it in
the ground just to be safe now it is
entirely possible and by the way
definitely wasn't a poached elephant so
to die of natural causes but I think
they were probably maybe worried that it
has a disease what's interesting here is
that that elephant that you're looking
at there with a long tusks she's got a
shorter tusks on the left hand side has
been very unhappy with us and we
initially she was the one that you
initially saw her lifting her head at us
towards us and displaying this pleasure
at our presence despite the fact that we
have never been closer than a hundred
meters to her so you know we really
haven't been pushing her it's not like
she's cornered in any way she just took
exception to our presence and we moved
back a bit and she got a little bit more
irritated and so he moved back further
and then she calmed down and then one or
two others of the herd shook their heads
at us and we think maybe that the bond
not far from here is perhaps a relative
of these ones and that these elephants
not to put too fine a point on it of
basically been at a funeral now I know
that that might sound ridiculous to many
of you many of you will go oh yes of
course that's obvious we know elephants
mourn and some of you may say well
there's no real evidence of that Hardy
proved that an elephant mourns well the
answer is you can't really I don't think
I've seen or heard about an experiment
that you can prove that has shown
without doubt that elephants mourn but
anybody who's ever owned a dog knows
when that dog is sad or when that dog is
happiest you know there's no question
that those dogs can't feel emotion we
know that elephants are hugely
intelligent we know that they have a
very high brain to body mass ratio or
brain volume to body mass ratio we know
that they're highly social and there's a
lot of anecdotal evidence to suggest
that they really do get very upset when
some of their own died so maybe it's
perhaps the old matriarch of this herd
that died here yesterday and they're all
just a bit tense and upset and sad by
the whole thing that was our guest here
on the vehicle Issac is on the vehicle -
so we were having a long chat about it
oh no blue monkey pig that couldn't be
why that herd was running the way
yesterday morning I remember that no
that was miles away that was up north we
were way down south near the Tanzanian
border at the moment in the sausage tree
prior and the sausage Republic as David
likes to call it yesterday's event took
place right near the Oliver gate the
completely other end of the reserve so
no it definitely didn't have anything to
do with what's going on here you are not
gonna push these elephants any further I
mean not that we have pushed him we're
gonna veer away from them now and head
down towards the sausages once we've
finished with the sighting I just love
the egrets that are flying in amongst
the grass great clouds of white egrets
there's a cattle egrets and they're
obviously just looking for insects and
that sort of thing
now apparently the great epic wall of
the dung beetles is ongoing so I think
we're going to send you back there I am
still here witnessing this very great
war at the moment and I'm gonna go back
there again and see what is happening at
the moment and I can promise you this
dung beetles are so very much skillful
because if you check the elephant
droppings they have got quite a lot of
things such as this materials but these
kind of beetles are able to seek
separate this kind of strong and hard
material and choose the soft elephants
can be able to eat about 400 kilograms
of food a day and after that they're
only going to digest only 48 percent
that is why in here is still quite a lot
of nutrients available there's even
quite a lot of water I can see here so
there's too much water here you can see
now that my stick is showing that this
elephant defecated here and urinated as
well somewhere in here so I can see that
here the droppings are having quite a
lot of moisture so here I can see this
defied the constructions and they fight
so this is amazing no this is too much
flies here at the moment as we saw them
earlier so these elephants are now
starting to concentrate on quite a lot
of they are concentrating on quite a lot
of Amarula I can see that maybe some of
these Amaru lots are now getting some
lot of water they might be now preparing
to arrive as normally the AMA rulers by
February is when we are starting to
drink the amar lobelia so you can see
that now they are trying to push where
these kind of a very big ball from the
ground is just let's just see how they
are going to manage to get out that kind
of a big ball and they are doing it
while fighting at the same time
you can hear the Cape Turtledove is also
calling somewhere here nearby saying
work hard work hard work hard work hard
so dung beetles are so very encouraged
by the capital job here you can see they
are coming out wet wait wait
so dung beetles they do carry diseases
as well look at that taking place so
these different types of dung beetles
and the most interesting one is the one
which is called the klepto corporate
klepto is just a term which means if
they are those who are waiting for the
ones who are rolling the balls come and
steal the ball and go away with the ball
they don't want to construct anything
all they want is to take over look at
that can see we are listening to each
other and they're shoving each other up
there the head is like a spade so now
let's let's go to Tristan see some bears
well on Torchwood at the moment and we
have a beautiful beautiful bird in fact
it's one of the most pretty bird summer
Birds we get it's a violets back to
styling you can see they're bright
yellow Eyring and in that plum kind of
color that shimmers in the light and a
white chase style that's the mail that
you seeing there he's very very pretty
and the females will surround some way
in that area there she is she doesn't
look like the same bird at all you can
see she's got a streaky little chest and
is all brown and drab in coloration in
compare comparison to the male but they
really are nice birds to see as if you
Cape turtledoves and also sitting on top
you know yes they look all right now I'm
sure Jamie's going to give me trouble
about Cape turtledoves because this
morning when said my
self and Jamie we're driving back from
Inga's off to the morning shift we went
past a tree and it looked like a wallet
at first looked like a sparrowhawks
house it is that a Sparrowhawk and it
turned out to be a cave Turtledove and
then Jamie said she's gonna make fun of
me so if you hear about it that's what
happened and somewhat ashamed and one of
those things are just the angle that we
were at but it looked like that but
anyway sim do you think you can get that
wild by crawling in the background there
now because it's Becky's got the kind of
lights on it so it's to the back right
of where they were so straight through
there to the right a little bit
but rights right right no not on that
she's back quite far back so like
somewhere there in the background or I
think it might have flow and
unfortunately sorry buddy
that's okay no worries it was just so is
catching the light quite nicely sir
thought it would be good but it was
somewhere in that area unfortunately has
flown away now the good news is is where
we are at the moment we found tracks for
both Tim garner and what looks like ton
D it looks like slightly big four to
elaborate difficult now with the two of
them they both have a similar sized
track but moving basically a pipeline
road and where we found them this
morning is on the other side of this
drainage so I think these tracks that
we've got are potentially tin goddess
tracks from this morning before he
crossed over but I think the ones from
tandy they look like they're on top of
his and so maybe she's come back to all
they the lumber was and his going to try
and see if she can pick her up so I'm
hoping if he loop around we'll be able
to get to the tracks for both of them
and hopefully find both of them which
would be quite nice and hopefully ting
up Siriano be really good you have a
family P them once again it's kind of
the best way imagine let's say bond the
back you never know these things happen
when the sames on the back so I'm gonna
back our luck and hope for the best and
see if we get this right so I'm sure we
can eventually but they track so just on
the left hand side yeah I think it's
you'll see them in the sand now that
looks like ton these track that we've
got yeah at the moment might be tin
Garner's I just need to see the size
roughly let's have a look
[Music]
could very well be ting Garner's track
that we've got there it looks like two
strikes maybe there you can just see it
up front and in this one that's close to
the car as well over there so that looks
like ting honest maybe a little bit big
for Tandy that particular one day so
this is kind of roughly where they've
been hanging around but it's good news
fast anytime there's signs of these guys
moving around it's always good and
hopefully it's going to be I've been
going to find them and there'll be some
way in this area the heat you say lipid
was spread do your thing yes well I
don't know if I'm going to be doing too
much whispering to there unfortunately
I'm not feeling very good that's all
I've feeling rather nausea and other
serious headache so sabes gonna have to
do all the whispering today hopefully
I'll skip myself sorted during the
course of the afternoon and by later
we'll get it right but it's not feeling
that's good so you have to try fade a
little bit hot babe
in the meantime let's send you back
across to Jamie who's still sitting with
the little chief
Oh shame put Tristan he apparently is
not feeling very well at all but I hope
he feels better I hope it's just the
heat and nothing else
it is very very warm and very sweaty out
here it's quite easy to dehydrate if
you're out on Safari
because you said something else to me
when you were linking to me but I was
distracted because I was talking on the
game drive radio at the same time if it
was urgent please let me know if not for
the rest of you I will tell you that you
can continue to send through your
questions oh good okay because it wasn't
that important I sincerely apologize I
was having two conversations and
worrying slightly about trust I hope
he's okay no we have one very sleepy
horse honor those of you who've been
watching since yesterday's sunset Safari
oh I see yes if anyone can whisper
leopards out of thin air Tristan Coun oh
those of you watching although that
husana is injured he has a nasty wound
on his left side on his left sort of leg
there at the join between the leg and
the and the belly the fine the belly
that is a very popular place for
injuries on big cats it seems to be the
place that I often see I'm just thinking
of when I look back on injuries I've
seen backs of legs and hips and that
area that join we've discussed it at
length what we think happened to him I
agree with Tristan I think it was most
likely a warthog it could also have been
the hoof or a horn of an animal that he
tried to grab but I don't
neither of us think that it was a cat I
don't think he was he had a take what's
the word well brain fried I don't think
he had an altercation with hook amore or
with his dad I think it was more likely
to be something that he was trying to
catch maybe he got a little
overconfident it could of course be a
hyena as well he's
oh but it's I don't think it's anything
should be concerned about it is
something that saw I'm sure it's hurting
him
it cannot be comfortable it is deep but
it doesn't go down doesn't look to me
like it's damaged any muscle layers so
it's deep down into the skin and it's
exposed the muscle but it doesn't look
as though it's injured in there Ali the
resilience of animals as you know always
takes us by surprise anyone's know how
long I think that wound will take to
heal it depends on infection and depends
of course upon whether or not he ends up
with a problem like we saw with the
Birmingham male years ago where the the
maggots actually infested that wound and
although they kept it clean they also
stopped it from healing for quite an
extended period of time if the same
thing happens to hasanah
it could actually take a month or two or
possibly even more to heal if it doesn't
you saw how Corky healed up from her her
lion attack wound the hyena she was
better in three weeks and I think that
husana will probably be the same I think
that's the most likely outcome I think
in three weeks time you'll barely be
able to see it there is also a
possibility he had a run-in with a lion
but again I don't think so I think we
would have seen bites puncture wounds I
don't think the injury looks like that
we'll never know though exactly what it
is that happened to him now Gabrielle
wants to know why do we not give him
medical help Gabrielle it's a big
question and one that we often get asked
first of all it's not our decision to
make it is not within our power to make
that call it's something that is decided
by the overall management of the area
that we're in called the sabi sand now
their policy is one of non-interference
unless the injury has been caused by
human beings now there are very very
solid reasons for this it sounds very
cold and a lot of people respond to that
by saying well you know we've destroyed
these animals habitat so much why is it
that we can't give them a helping hand
in order to
keep them you know to help them out
given how much we've damaged their
population and it's a fair enough point
and there's a lot of room for compassion
within conservation but nature does
things best so nature knows her balanced
nature knows what is needed and nature
has her way of not weeding out
necessarily the weak but certainly there
are it's a very difficult line to draw a
natural injury like us is going to heal
I don't think I'll sign a needs medical
intervention if he was seen with the
snare a metal piece of wire the Titans
that set out by bushmeat poachers we
would immediately step in we would
immediately call the authorities and
they would come in to help us but by and
large what the approach is here is to
let nature run its course and it has
proved itself time and again a hundred
years ago we decided as human beings not
we personally because we weren't around
a hundred years ago but it was decided
that the best way of conserving the
animals in this area was to shoot all
the Predators because they were eating
the the antelope and that meant that was
the conservation norm that was how
people thought they were protecting this
area by interfering to that point wild
dogs leopards lions they all had to go
because they were damaging the
population of game bizarre to us now
now as times have moved on we've moved
more in the direction of allowing nature
to take her course because interfering
causes all sorts of problems it also
costs an immense amount of money which
is obviously well spent in situations
where it is human caused but otherwise
is justified more being spent conserving
this area as a whole and protecting not
one leopard but every single animal in
this entire area so it is a difficult
one in its one it's a it's a concept
that a lot of people struggle with and I
understand it's human to do so we want
to help but that level of interference
certainly here is not necessary I'll
give you another example because I think
I suspect that you new to this debate
I'll give you another example
with the Cubs with mange the sticks Cubs
had mange the in coma Cubs had mange
there was a lot of a distress that was
caused to a lot of people watching the
Cubs
really suffer and they did suffer and
eventually all eight sticks Cubs died
the Inca home is on the other hand
didn't now there is a natural degree of
resilience there obviously their
genetics somehow helped them out a
little bit along the way it also helped
that it did start to rain of course as
well but in now what we've seen is
they're in comas they're Lions have been
constantly exposed to mange by the
mangani males who've been spending time
with them and all of those Cubs who
survived have been have not even been
affected badly by the mange at all
they've competed it's totally passed
them by now if they had been treated
they would not have built up that
resilience and immunity and to make that
decision is very very difficult
where for me personally where I start to
struggle is not in situations like this
I'm comfortable with letting hosts on a
hill on his own hey my boy yes I am it
doesn't mean I love you any less
it really doesn't I do love you but I
love you as a wild animal and as you
should be a newbie should be free where
I start to struggle is where an animal
is clearly at the point of suffering and
they're going to die and I struggle with
not being able to step in to end that
suffering then again there have been
cases where I've watched an animal
suffering convinced that it's going to
die and it's recovered on its own so you
know it's a very very difficult line to
draw and no one can shout anyone down
for not having or for having that
compassion but it's a question of really
thinking about it a little bit more
clearly and with a bit of all a bit of
healthy dose of reality I guess
unfortunately and I say that without
being cruel the truth is nature does
things better
it's extraordinary also how people it's
and I find it particularly with hyenas
how people often step in when they see
an injured leopard or a lion and they go
we must treat it and then that's
something like a hyena walks past with
two broken back legs and continues on
without the same outcry human beings by
nature myself included can be very
hypocritical here we fine
I'm not worried we'll keep a close eye
on it we'll watch for signs of infection
flies dolls sitting on it which i think
is why so Restless lie on it my boy lone
had put it down in the cold dirt that
will help so well husana lie is down in
his preferred spot for the moment let's
go to lying Lions in the Maasai Mara
writing here we have found you can see
an astonishing lion sighting here now
what these Lions are doing is lying in
ambush waiting for the elephants they're
almost certainly going to kill one of
the elephants and have it for supper so
you can see their strategy is perfect
the elephants coming slowly closer
towards them and to flatten themselves
into the grass in order to create the
ambush situation there is little one
there that's flicking its tail up and
down is sort of trying to attract the
curiosity of the elephant so they'll
come here a little bit faster I'm
obviously talking utter garbage this is
the sausage tree pride it is not all of
them we think it's three cubs and three
adult lionesses in fact that's
definitely what it is and so we're
missing two lionesses which is very
exciting
probably not far from here in the stream
or brook that we have sort of running
past this area and possibly with new
tiny baby little cubbies are we gonna
hang around here because this is
obviously the most bankable sighting for
our TV show later on today and hopefully
these cats will get up and do something
other than what they're doing now
especially that they have their little
ones with them I don't think the
elephants know that the Lions are here
at all I think that the Lions may be
forced to move as a result of the
elephants I'll be quite grateful to the
elephants if that is the case
very little sound just a very upset I
think it's probably cicadas species
going back in the background now scenic
a big male line could never kill an
elephant unless the elephant was on its
very last legs a big male elephant of
course weighs 5 tons of big male lion
weighs 200 kilograms and so these
highest difference is is well it's
phenomenal really what is it it's fires
25 times the size and a big male lion
might be able to ride on the back of an
elephant but you certainly couldn't kill
it
you do hear stories of elephants being
killed by lions often in drought
conditions in places like savuti in
botswana but it is very uncommon well
it's not that uncommon I suppose in the
dry season with young elephants but it's
very uncommon as would they ever be an
adult elephant once an elephant gets
passed over ten years old really unless
it's very sick it's going to be tough
for pride of lions or enormous clan of
hyenas to take it down
now the little Cubs are watching
enjoying this game viewing experience in
the Mara their neighbors I'm sure will
fill them with a sense of curiosity and
also not a little fear that's so sweet
no wonderful it's a lovely picture
you can see the adults are not vaguely
concerned haven't even bother to lift
their heads over there comes a head
I predict it'll go strapped down again
mm-hmm but of course little weapons who
haven't seen too many elephants in their
short time here on planet earth this is
all very exciting as is chewing the bush
in front of you
all righty I'm gonna wait and see what
happens here we're gonna go back across
to her sauna now I believe he's at the
thirsty alright well James that sees
what happens there we are sitting with
the lovely Hosanna who's decided to
quench his thirst I suspect
judging from his behavior today I think
that that wound is very saw today I
think that it's quite saw I think it's
making hot I think it might be a little
bit infected I haven't seen a property
to really confirm that though because it
took me a while to get around to where
he is at the moment drinking from a
truly fetid looking water source if I'm
quiet you can just hear him laughing I
think maybe over the sounds of the birds
maybe not
arrey thirsty boy well as long as he
keeps eating keeps drinking
you can walk he's not limping
it's not limping too badly so I think it
won't affect his ability to hunt
it's very beautiful down here it really
is and although summer has made our
lives more difficult in terms of binding
animals certainly spotting them in the
thick vegetation or even just trying to
track them it does mean that everything
is that much more beautiful to look at
the goal of a leopard contrasting about
the Verdon against the verdant green to
use James's word is truly spectacular
a scoop says that husana is hunting
tadpoles right now here's the little
source of protein maybe just a little
pick-me-up imagine how scary it must be
for the tadpoles because they do like to
hang about the edges of these pools it's
not my relatively shadow where they can
look up there especially in dirty water
where they can perhaps see whatever
they're after mosquito a lobby or
whatever it happens to be I'm sure there
was one sad pole that went swimming away
and they all went dashing off
Lilly says that he is very thirsty he is
I can't blame him I have to say I'm very
thirsty too and I've just realized I
finished my entire bottle of water and
it's only sure what time is it's only
just after 5:00 which means you're still
got another two and a half hours to go
I'm going to need to start carrying five
litre water bottles it is it's a thirsty
kind of a day it's definitely a lot of
humidity in the air there's another
storm building up over the mountains
that isn't going to get to us I've given
up thinking it's going to rain for now
so yes he's thirsty I think I think he's
very restless honestly I think he saw it
must be very painful
that injury there is constantly moving
or in the area that he's constantly
moving will also mean that it's rate of
healing is going to be slightly slower
it's not as though an animal can go and
rest a wild animal like this he can't be
put to bed
with the thermometer in his mouth and a
bandage around his wounds I was lying in
the watery mud now trying to cool down
those of you who've experienced high
temperatures as in in terms of internal
body temperature when you've had a fever
you'll know what this feels like when
you've got a fever and it's hot outside
it's just the absolute worst which was
why I was eternally grateful when I had
malaria that we had aircon in the
bedroom it just made such a difference
to my recovery and made me think of all
those poor people who get malaria
regularly in Africa who don't
don't have access to the medication or a
fan or anything to help to keep them
cool it's horrible
being ill and it's been boiling hot
outside lots of flies about down here a
sauna it's much cooler out of the
strange line I have to tell you it
really is there's a breeze you're not
going to take my advice because he
doesn't understand
remember a year ago when husana does it
was about a year ago it was when he fell
out of a tree and he developed a limp
and we were all terribly comfortable
with vaguely concerned about him not to
worry just a little bit okay while we
search to make sure the little chief
doesn't vanish on us before the TV show
let's go across to James who has found
himself some elephants
I thought there may be a little bit of a
roar there that's why I was silent for a
second you know it was just a yawn
as you could see the inexorable hunt is
underway the elephants are walking into
the ambush and the Lions have perked up
slightly yeah I think I can hear Kerstin
talking Malone you're talking to us no
general comes okay sorry about that
everybody we've got two radios on the on
the car I thought maybe that my idea had
malfunctioned
why hasn't now if you look to the right
there I think that elephant the little
one on the left of the right hand herd
lifted its trunk up and maybe spotted
the Lions Kermie
yes elephants would killed lion cubs if
lion cubs didn't move out the way they
wouldn't go out of their way to kill
them in the same way that a buffalo
would but certainly the elephant's would
be a danger to their more to the adults
but also to the Cubs are we getting a
little bit of play behavior which is
nice and it's a bit of cuddling going on
to the left of that too one game there
we go fun lion cuddling they do like to
cuddle do Lions just like my mother's
cat
they also adore when they do that and
who will ever forget the sighting of
Jamie Patterson Amba eyes and one of
amber eise's nephews or nieces and amber
eyes hugging it yes JW I am absolutely
being completely sarcastic about this
ambush this is not an ambush
this is just a coincidental meeting of
two species the elephant's happen to be
grazing up the hill the Lions on a hot
day were lying under the only tree that
was convenient to them and now they're
going to have a meeting which will
consist of the Lions getting up and
loping off for somewhere else and the
elephant's walking past now you can see
all right so they're probably about 70
meters away or so
and the limes on the right have now
perked up they're quite interested
I mean to scratch my head then to be
brutally honest I was to pick my hat or
charger I could have a sip of tea I
thought I can't lie to you we know each
other we know each other well enough now
for me to tell you that I'm having some
tears I what does wonderful citing what
a way to spend a Sunday afternoon
elephants the ala Lolo Scotland in the
background smell of a wood fire which I
hope will go out fairly soon Sun about
to sit a sausage tree pride and their
cubs having a bit of a cuddle in a play
I kept a Kenyan tea in my hand for and
they call this work
I'm gonna be very careful not to slip my
tea because Kirsten finds it very an
unpleasant Michelle I normally agree
that coffee is better but at this time
the afternoon tea is what you want
ideally with a cream scone we don't have
cream scones we do have some superb Lee
roasted nuts and so I've had a couple of
nuts and mighty Christmas cake would
also be wonderful actually
something also tremendously comforting
about the smell of a wood fire even if
it is a one that seems to be slightly
wild upon the murder you have your Earl
Grey I'm having normal tea grown here in
Kenya salon T I suppose you'd call it I
do like a bit of Earl Grey
this is just I mean it's just gonna
slowly get bitter and bitter I'm sure
many of you sitting there I was thinking
jealously of my position here yeah I was
saying this yesterday and I really do
believe it that oh she's got a collar on
let me see that
sorry about that she's obviously being
monitored quite carefully it's not
particularly comfortable does it say I'm
sure she's used to it by now and I was
saying yesterday that I I must
constantly be aware that you know you
obviously whatever job you do you get
tired
from time to time but this particular
job I do need to constantly remind
myself of how unspeakably lucky I am to
call what I'm doing right now work I
think back to my days as a guitar
teacher back in Johannesburg and what I
used to do on Sunday afternoons there
and it's the growing grade for the week
starts to build I don't feel that at all
anymore just very special indeed
biologically there's not a huge amount
of interesting thing or stuff going on
here these elephants will probably spot
the Lions eventually their eyes are not
fantastic I don't think they're as bad
as a lot of people will head you will
have you believe
if the elephant's become aware of the
Lions one or two might take a few steps
towards them if they stay at this
distance and kind of graze around
I suspect that we're actually
inadvertently protecting the lands from
the elephants because we're parked
directly behind them I don't think
that's going to affect the outcome
tremendously except that it might allow
the Lions to lie here for a bit longer
does the elephants are going to avoid
walking straight at us but other than
that everything is very calm and
peaceful here and in fact you can see
the Lions settling in again
there won't be particularly worried
about the situation because of course
they know there are much faster than
elephants and I suspect also they
realize that despite the fact that I
don't an outright sprint and that alt
elephant could probably outrun one of
these cubs they know that the elephants
will probably not push home and attack
if they back off fast enough there's the
same probably wouldn't be said for her
to Buffalo coming this way
so just starting now to make their
evening calls down on the brook bellows
and the thick trees
I'm car sorry miss dad was at how far
can elephants feed in a day in an area
like this I don't think they're moved
tremendously far but it's probably a
good 5 or 6 kilometers I suppose how far
can they see well there we go that like
that elephants now spotted a lot there
we go and that's at a distance of about
50 meters look at them she's she's told
all the rest
she's infrasonic li told all the others
that they were proud of that there's a
pride of lions yeah they're now all
completely alert look at that
only one elephant saw these cats and
they all reacted straight away the
elephants did and they're moving away
that's really very interesting I've seen
elephants do exactly the opposite of
this and chase the Lions away but maybe
because we hear they decided not to do
that so um car I don't know I mean look
I don't know what distance they're able
to see accurately at but you know I
think it depends on what sort of terrain
they're in so could they see me walking
across an open plain at a hundred metres
yes definitely they could absolutely
that's at 330 feet could they see me or
could I successfully walk through some
thick bush in front of them at 100
metres if I didn't make a noise yes I
probably could there probably wouldn't
pick me up then
they do apparently also have a blind
spot and if you approach them straight
side on and they're feeding they won't
see you I've never tried that myself
I've read about it from a very reliable
source
I wouldn't try that now they're running
I mean that bunch is totally taking off
that's why I think that what frightened
those elephants yesterday morning
remember we had that long line of
elephants running with the matriarch
standing at the back shimmying them
along I think that they must have seen a
predator now they've stopped look they
will stopped at the same time someone's
told them to stop somebody said hang on
wait
now probably all start moving as one
again go all of that is being
communicated
most likely with infrasound
brings up two questions here the first
one is why is it that they should be
afraid of these lions there is no real
reason for them to be afraid yes they
are trying to protect their youngsters
and in theory I suppose three lionesses
they don't know how many lionesses there
are here could take down a very small
one but they should know by now that
they're not going to try and take down a
small one in amongst a group big group
of adults and it must have something to
do with their ancient past there's
something in their biology or something
in prehistory that has made them this
reactive to predators and I can only
think it must have been an experience or
you know a millennia of experience with
big saber-toothed cats much bigger
predators than in these lions who posed
a genuine threat to elephants and their
babies who were able to spook the herd
make them run and then take one up
because they reacted much as I might
Wild Dogs even and there's no way the
wild dogs ever gonna take down an
elephant
stunning little sighting that really
lovely and the light is now coming out
my tea is finished in case you were
wondering
Valkyr dog you say that was incredible
to watch yes it was marvelous to watch
most official
now one gauge you want some light on
these lines or do you want them backlit
um okay let's move just slightly forward
and then we'll get a better look at the
lines you pleased with that
I'll Drive gently so the mats don't go
all over the place in fact while I do
that we're going to go across the cities
for a small update
I have just left the dung beetles not
long time ago and now I am heading much
more towards the chitwa chitwa to go and
see if we cannot find any of the
interesting animals that side so there's
just elephant tracks every way so those
are the tracks
I have seen here see I okay our game
reserves and this elephants that affects
our editing the much more towards the
very same direction maybe we might be
lucky much smaller side and see the
biggest animal
so this area here we are this is the
fire break is the area we saw they
attack while being in the bush I haven't
been attacked but I have been charged
I've been charged not once not twice
something very important about working
in the bush is that you must always
expect unexpected because animals can
easily hide behind the bushes and before
you see them they see you so which means
I can be walking now trying to approach
an animal which is there while not
seeing another animal which is somewhere
much closer so those kind of challenges
they do happen while we are doing some
operations here in the wild so I just
want to show you the area we have been
seeing a lot earlier by the end of last
year this was the fire break the fire
brick which was open now look at the
recovery this bush is recovering there's
only a little bit of a bare pages at the
moment you can see that the grasses are
coming back heavily and when the grasses
are starting to get excited like this it
gives us a scone the fist a big sign
that this year possibilities of having
heavy fires in different areas are high
because too much red grouse grasses and
too much grasses then becomes a lot of
fuel which will then facilitate a lot of
fires during the fire season so it's
good to have raised but rains at the
same time they do bring us a lot of
grasses and fires can only get excited
by the heavy fuel
so it means in in order to predict the
amount of oil you're going to have by
next year
now when the rain is still growing and
the recovery is happening is when you
can tell
so the bush it does go through different
kind of assessments these animals when
you are seeing them here feeding every
day is something which is called failed
condition assessment the bush has to be
assessed in order to see if it can still
capacitate the animals who are feeding
on them so that is done through process
called default condition assessment
where we check the key on this process
the grasses we check how many grazers
and all these different kind of browsers
so now let's cross over to James
our son is still enjoying list of all
not quite follow that he's found himself
but you were talking earlier about water
and why he doesn't just go and lie in
the water he isn't lying in the water
but he's found himself the next best
thing
he's found himself some mud that's not
it's not waterlogged so it's not
sticking to him he's not sinking into it
but it's just enough to cool him down
ever so slightly he was briefly
interested in something rustling in the
the pile of dried-up dead tree behind
him looks like it was a nob thorn at one
point in its life it is now no longer so
something was in there and it was
obviously making a bit of noise so he
went to go and try and stick his head in
there and unfortunately thought better
of it because I think that probably
would have resulted potentially in the
loss of an eye or an eye injury which I
don't think he needs to add to his list
of woes I'm sure you will all agree okay
boy see how restless he is it's been
like this all afternoon up down up down
up down nice cool spot I'm sure he's got
a temperature I reckon if you were able
to sit hold him still for long enough
and take his temperature it would be a
few points of a degree over what it
should be
child of the universe wants to know how
you avoid dehydration in such heat now
us as humans well obviously we've got as
a degree of control over how we go about
this whole process we do a lot of
sweating a lot more sweating than most
animals so we do lose a lot of water in
the way that we cope with that is
obviously just rehydrating constantly
and if anyone shows any signs similar to
or Tristan's been dealing with today and
what we'll usually do is try and give a
little bit of rehydrate as well just to
replenish so the the salt balance within
the body because obviously drinking
waters all fine and well and for most of
us it's usually fine it's enough
combined with a bit of food to keep us
well balanced as long as you drink you
have to drink a lot but you'll find that
you do automatically you find that you
just drink double triple the amount that
you would if it was say a average 75
degree fahrenheit day you just
automatically drinking all the time if
you can and then obviously staying cool
if possible a lot of people are adapted
quite well to dealing with heat out here
because we live out here you'll find
that someone who isn't often will will
struggle a little bit in the beginning
but for those of us that are familiar
with it it's it's not too unbearable you
just have to keep drinking water and on
and on until you you make sure that you
don't dehydrate for the animals
obviously there's lots of water around
at the moment fortunately out here high
temperatures coincide with the rainy
season which means there is water
available for them to drink so they will
drink more than normal there are certain
animals of course that are adapted to
replenish the water that they lose or
sorry not replenish the water that they
lose to minimize the amount of water
that they use for example the feedback
system within an Oryx which allows them
to cool the blood before it goes to the
part of their brain that is receptive to
temperature internal temperature so that
it actually tricks the brain into
thinking the animal is not as hot as it
is
at the same time also it means that the
brain doesn't overheat or get too hot
it's basically a you know it's where
blood flows one way up against cold
blood flow and it helps to keep it cool
before it goes to the brain I can't
think of the word I'm looking for child
of the universe says that they're
drinking more water just watching us I
know you got to keep drinking stay
hydrated folks I was going to make a
sarcastic comment but I'm going to hold
back stay hydrated no tea and coffee on
a day like today lest you find yourself
dehydrating yourself even further shame
my boy it's sore Hey he returned he
settles then I think the Flies land and
it's just really really uncomfortable
for him
pity shame
very South African thing to say shame
well this because I'm feeling sorry for
him
oh we're busy feeling sorry for
ourselves in this heat
James is absolutely right whenever we
think of it as a job we have to remind
ourselves how lucky it is that we are to
be in this job and that means taking in
the sunset
we've moved slightly and you can see
we're now facing well Southwest and
that's where the Sun is going down
behind the a little over escarpment
shortly and in front of the tree that
Bungay insisted I parked behind or you
can see the Lions well you will be able
to see them as the camera slowly exposes
for the ground beautiful
it's an interesting thing that staying
hydrated a discussion that you're having
because one of the greatest
misconceptions about dehydration and
about heatstroke exhaustion is that the
more water you drink the safer you'll be
and that is not in fact true because you
lose a huge amount of salt if you sweat
a great deal and drinking too much water
can result in renal failure and another
condition which whose name might
naturally have forgotten because of a
lack of salt and that can be potentially
fatal and is actually much more
dangerous than a little bit of
dehydration and in fact it's the
greatest cause of medical emergencies in
marathon running so you have immuno you
have these med medical tents at the end
of marathons and very seldom do people
rush into the tent in a state of
dehydration they run in because they've
drunk too much and the salts in their
bodies have diluted so much that their
organs start to shut down so you've got
to balance the amount of water you drink
and increase it with a little bit of
salt these chaps have no such worry of
course because it is beautifully cool
here I'd say the temperature is probably
now about 25 degrees Celsius 75
Fahrenheit
there isn't a breath of wind that will
change as the Sun Goes Down and pretty
sure will get a slight northerly breeze
as the Sun Goes Down I mean that is just
too cute isn't it lovely
still suckling for those of you who are
not familiar with these liens if you
have perhaps just joined us I'm and fain
would be very happy to welcome you if
you have just joined us and being loved
lovely to know if you are watching for
the first time this is the sausage tree
pride consists of five females and three
three Cubs and we suspect at least one
more litter of small Cubs that have yet
to be introduced to the pride all three
of these Cubs male two of them are five
months old plus - the other is four
months old plus - they are will they
fall under the ambit of the old Daniel
pike males - males who be examined in
great detail yesterday from behind and
between them they appear to only have
one testicle which i think is quite well
very sad for them but very interesting
from the point of view of how they're
going to leave some sort of genetic
legacy here is kinky tail
hello Michelle you say you here for the
first time allow me to introduce you to
kinky tail the most famous lioness of
the sausage tree pride she is about to
pop look how heavy her belly is she
hasn't given birth yet you can see her
nipples are very swollen but they're
dirt and if need on't have any suckle
marks on them I'm actually quite
surprised that these youngsters haven't
tried to suckle offer despite the fact
that she hasn't given birth yet I must
also say for those of you who have been
watching for a while there's no question
that I was wrong when I was here last I
know I know it's impossible to believe
but it's true I was wrong when I was
here last because I said that one of the
lionesses was definitely going to give
birth very soon and I think she was Jack
she just full I'm pretty sure that you
were pregnant but she didn't give birth
with three weeks that I thought she was
going to can we have a look at that
rather interesting pose of their lioness
under the tree has
has struck as she watches the sunset I
think that is very special many of you
shocked that kinky stet tail is still
pregnant I know his shocking isn't it
but it won't be for long she's going to
give birth shortly via magic to catch
that on camera wouldn't magic dragon
wizard given that you or the magical one
I don't know that I'm qualified to
answer this better than you can you say
how many Cubs do I think that she has in
there I don't know I mean the average
for lions is somewhere between three and
six so around about four I guess I've
never seen a litter of five though I
mean all six so I'm gonna say three or
four in there maybe it's begun I doubt
it though she also doesn't look like she
ate a great deal yesterday that Buffalo
and I suspect that's because it's just
too deeply uncomfortable how much that
every time I see a heavily pregnant
female anything I'm again grateful for
the y-chromosome that I was blessed with
I will never have to endure pregnancy I
suppose for those of you who are mothers
it must come with its advantages
but I have enormous respect for any
female mammal who has to carry
youngsters to term and especially out
here where there is no sympathy for the
pregnant
there's certainly no mollycoddling by
the time birth takes place it clipped
amongst the elephants interesting Lee so
these lines I mean she'll have to take
herself off and give birth on her own
any kind of help no one will be around
her to give her any kind of assistance
and the elephant's birth is almost
celebrated it's very sweet the rest of
the herd will surround the elephant herd
all the elephant mother and watch her
give birth and protect her and look
after her magic dragon was if you say
three cups well that's very good I'm
glad you were able to tell through or to
have a bowl or crystal ball you were
looking in well she has three cubs
it is a perfect afternoon so those are
the two mothers the soon-to-be mother we
think another one of them
well eyes except me thinks that she's
got Cubs down below in the brook below
us Brook stream gully lager small river
whatever you like to call it I think
he's probably right advice I think that
probably all be here and in case you
weren't watching yesterday there are of
course still fat full and satisfied
after the buffalo they ate
that hugging is just too sweet
we've got to have exactly the right time
everyone we had hardly any flat cat it's
not too hot and so they've got a little
bit more active than one would expect
perhaps at this time of the day oh you
can hear them
you hear that
just a little bit of very satisfied
grunting and groaning
and it really is to magic the scene I
can't imagine a more magical type of a
scene really for a Sunday afternoon a
cup of tea in my hand
of course by the time the TV show comes
along what they'll all be doing is lying
as flat as humanly buzzer lyalya nini
possible in the grass and we will get
one ear flicking for the duration I hope
that it isn't the case
and as is exactly the same with my
nephews everyone plays nicely for a
while until somebody gets a little bit
rough with someone else
and then there are tears
all righty we're not moving anywhere
from this magical scene let's go back to
Tristan Dix the leopard was deprived his
whispering succeeds well I'm sure not
chance Islands absolutely magical
between the golden lights and the little
playful Cubs it's about as good as one
could ever ask for and it's something
about that light that you gets in the
Mara that really kind of um it's very
very special now we've had can he be
described as a bit of a frustrating
afternoon we've got alarm calls of
guinea fowl farm the guinea fowls up in
the tree which is normally a surefire
sign that a leopard has just walked
there can't find them anywhere and got
no signal in those areas we've now
tracking Tigana
which are fresh tracks because I found
ray he was in the grass that he was
sleeping on hasn't even stood up yet
it's still flat on the ground completely
and the tracks were pretty good but I
just can't he kind of cuts into a block
and I haven't found anything coming arch
it's and it's why I'm going so slowly at
the moment because I'm trying to see if
he comes out onto this road he was
coming from my right side towards this
kind of area and there was some more
toast what are you see sir you see a
raptor okay come on rusty these kids are
not doing well it looks like a
Wahlberg's Eagle and we've got in the
tree itself just double-check with me
yes pal form Walberg so they're sitting
there nice long rectangular tail little
crest and it's being dive-bombed as you
can see why those forked tail drongos
the junglers are having a bit of a go at
them and it's actually sometimes worth
finding a raptor like this and just
sitting and listening so you spent a bit
of time on first rock itself because
ting ghana where we found him where he
was lying was just below first rock we
found a little tree that he had been
underneath for probably the majority of
today and you know that's a great area
just to stop and listen for in his hands
away Niall on calls or anything like
that sand we haven't heard too much so I
think wherever he may be he's either
lying down again and is sleeping
underneath the tree somewhere or he is
moved quite far out of this area but I
don't think so like I say that
that place where he was lying the grass
has definitely stood up which I mean
which is difcil flattened and normally
once the pressures lifted the grass will
slowly start to come back up again and
kind of stand and we'll show that he's
kind of been a long time since he was
this I'm hoping he's not too far away
I'll just keep scratching the good thing
is he looks like he's walking back
towards Juma which will help our signal
for this evening if we can find him but
that Wahlberg's Eagle is taking it very
easy the other problem that we've got
this the cards are coming in now and the
wind has dropped and it's starting to
get rather warm
once again anyway we're gonna keep
looking when a trial very best to find
this kept before the end of Drive in the
meantime it sends you back across to
James and the beautiful sunset and lines
starting to get a bit warm Samsung has
been warm for weeks there's Juma well
the consistency of the Mara weather has
been a joy for us over here
good luck Tristan I do wish you the very
best of luck you've got 45 minutes until
TV stops all the best
and I say there's a rising panic when
you've been out for three hours already
TV starting at half an hour and you've
got one grasshopper to show a few
efforts it's a it's it's not an easy
thing to deal with emotionally I have
often experienced it right we're now
going to attempt sunset to Bungay
remember yesterday film do an epic
sunset we're trying to do the same again
today okay I will just warn you and tell
you that the secret sequel is often not
as good as the first movie but let's see
if you can do it here when the TV show
is going to be live from South Africa
today on s ABC 3 at 6:30 p.m. at 7:30
p.m.
East African time it'll be me and Sidney
and Jamie interestin and whatever
animals we can find all right let's be
quiet for 20 seconds and just appreciate
this amazing scene
just once a sticker the temperature in
the background
no insect sound
it slowly as the Sun goes what will
happen is that foreground that you can
see lighten up as the Sun has touched
the mountains a little breeze has come
up it's not from the north it's coming
from the south
now swinging down to the waist
the Lions have stopped playing now it's
almost as they appreciate this very
almost sacred time of the day I think
that's the best way to put it
I'll just be patient because you'll see
as the Sun disappears the foreground is
gonna brighten up and you'll see the
Lions
and their reverent observation of the
Alba going behind the alalanatha
Scotland
down towards Lake Victoria I think
just a ream Macduff away in the distance
and I slowly you'll see the foreground
come
look at them
watching in reverence and that wonderful
it really does feel like they have
come to appreciate it in much the same
way Thomas you say you appreciate the
silence er it is such a rare thing in
our lives isn't it as I say that does it
cheetah flying over the top of us and I
suppose it's
wonderful sort of indication of why our
lives as herself silent technology has
made them pretty noisy
of course the bush is not ever really
silent but it feels silent because the
noises are all natural
our sons gone down the reference with
which they've watched it isn't over
the evening will continue for these
predominantly nocturnal creatures
coastal islands to her to quiet places
to deliver their babies he'll probably
go down into like I say a secluded spot
where there's a cave or an overhang or
something that they can hide their cubs
in in order to make sure that they're
safe and not you know put under or not
not easily found by potential predators
there we go
in a time now
the sun's entertainment is over
right well I'm not sure how reverently
ho Sandra's watching the heat of the low
felt summer let's go and see marshmallow
Sun is enjoying the heat of the low felt
very much this afternoon I am I don't
mind heat too much I really would prefer
to be too hot so than too cold
there's Walt now and I'm considerably
sweaty and it's going to be an
interesting TV show so I'm going to be
able to sort of well clearly perspiring
let's put it that way I'm going to be at
a tower sort of best we're going to be a
bit bedraggled but all of us persona is
fine Steve mentioned an injury on his
right side as well I haven't seen
anything yet rosemary you want to know
how hot it is at night on Juma I would
say that it's it's probably around about
between 25 to 30 degrees depending on
the day we had and if we've had wind
last night was actually quite nice
because after the hot day the wind blew
in quite strongly and that helps to take
the temperature down a little bit to
probably around about I think we would
have started this morning at around 25
so mid seventies Fahrenheit it's not
it's nothing like when was a 2016 so mm
yes twas was 2016 when we we were
absolutely baking hot we really were
I'm completely perplexed I now cannot
remember 2016 at all okay I don't know
the passage of time is confusingly quick
off you go across to tristin who's sort
of found well something with spots well
Jamie and 2016 was horrendous in terms
of heat but interestingly enough we have
I you know with suckle marks on torture
it that is right we are we looking for
ting Ghana you can see look the soil and
Bailey they with MOOC so all of you that
know how to identify all of these hyenas
may be a good time to look and this
hyenas got its nose in the air I wonder
if ting Ghana is not somewhere here
might be worth following the sign of
this is the exact direction that the
tracks came in and the way that this
hyenas walking around it's got its nose
up and is smelling but I want to know
who it is I I mean I think it could be
June that we sing and what she's doing
and tortured I'm not quite sure the ears
were pretty good and intact which is a
feature of June so I want to just try
and see if I can kind of see where she
goes if we can just kind of keep
parallel with her as she's walking along
I don't necessarily want to sort of
off-road too far but that's the exact
kind of routes I would have expected to
garner to take I unfortunately haven't
seen him in this area but I know is
she's going so let's just try and get
background but the last time we followed
I you know we were successful in that we
found husana in the way that she's got
her nose down to the ground it almost
looks as though she can sniff out
something that potentially we cons so
I'm just gonna quickly get in luck in
the Gacy now she's turned and come back
our way which means I have a funny
feeling he's walked this direction
already and I've just missed his track
crossing this road it's pretty tricky on
this road to see tracks nicely but the
way that she's kind of nose down
sniffing that's how hyenas do it when
they follow leopards is that they get
their nose to the ground
and then they end up kind of sniffing
about you see that see how she's kind of
very different posture so what she had
just now she's working out hang on wait
at this leopard go and they do this
regularly because they know often
leopard might lead them to food and so
they will actively track leopard like me
well in order to try and figure out we
they are and he might lead us straight
to him if we're lucky but you see that
more clear you can see it heavily on her
tummy and those years are pretty perfect
which means that it's definitely not
hokey or pretty so who are you and we
are your Cubs because that is heavy
heavy milk that she's got there just
trying to see is it Juna no nice kind of
circle on his shoulder so it might very
well be here but you see how she's
smelling I think she can pick up the
symptoms in Ghana which is good news for
us like I say if we just patient and
maybe follow her through we might
actually be able to find our lipid as
well so are you going to use an animal
this time as a tracker and see how it
goes the way that she's got her nose to
the ground is positive for us because
she's not following my scent she's most
definitely following the scent of
potentially waiting on his walk so we're
just gonna turn around and see where she
goes it's gotten very very humid all of
a sudden
so charcoal you reckon it is June so
June where are you keeping your babies
if you are milling about in the middle
of Torchwood I'm curious now if maybe
her den isn't on tortured somewhere the
way that she's milling about here is at
this time of the day and this heat I
can't expect her den to be too far away
I suppose she might not have gone back
to the little Cubs this morning so it's
potentially that's you know they're not
her on but so that hyenas on the March
it starts as nose down and is sniffing
everywhere amazing the senses these
animals have I'd said before we lose it
let's catch up there
so June is exciting and there's
definitely cup somewhere there that
amount of milk is being produced it's
got to be that she has cubs somewhere
good we gonna keep following maybe
she'll take us back to the Cubs maybe
she'll take us Tooting Ghana who knows
either way it'll be interesting that
send you back across though to James in
the meantime as he still sits with his
lions was very exciting this for the
Jews first litter I imagine she's got
Cubs I hope that she's dead somewhere on
Jun more tortured the Lions here
continue to play which fills means the
great sins of great because my great
fear of course is that they're going to
be fast asleep
come hot six from half past seven East
African time
imagine having your head inside that
lionesses mouth I wouldn't like that
isn't it interesting how all animals
have this knowledge somehow of what
constitutes gentle play behavior versus
actual aggression how they understand
what will cause pain and what won't to a
large extent and playing with a dog is a
wonderful example of doing that we have
a dog in Kenton where I spend a lot of
my time and my father's dog whose name
is Hinton and Fenton is amazingly good
at not biting my handle which is big
kind of him and he's a very powerful
jaws but he knows when he's playing and
he doesn't ever break the skin well he
sometimes does but that's by mistake and
I'm amazed that animals know how to do
that now if you look at these lions they
obviously know precisely what's too hard
and what's gentle enough with their cubs
can we have a look at the fire there on
Gabe you don't mind you can actually see
the flames no I don't think anything is
in danger there I don't think there's a
huge amount to burn simply because the
grass is pretty green but it's a bigger
fire than I thought it was I'm pretty
sure it'll go out in the night it's not
moving at any great speed but it seems
to have be radiating out from a central
point in fact it's exactly what it's
doing it's radiating in a circle so it
was set in one spot and it's burning up
from there all right everybody that's
going to be it from this end of the
Safari I'll see you tomorrow if you're
not going to join us for the SABC show I
will see you tomorrow at 5 o'clock
central african time that's six o'clock
east african time thank you very much
for your questions and your comments as
always they are much appreciated
especially for those of you who spoke to
us for the very first time until
tomorrow thank you and bye bye